[Music]
it seems like there's a good reason to
talk about this just because it happened
with it yesterday or a few days ago uh
if you followed this story about the
google employee who
who declared lambda one of the ai bots
the silliness
with which
such a large fraction of our collective
intelligence
was effusively oriented towards
something
is is just evidence
of the ease by which a relatively
mediocre ai
if improperly deployed
could take advantage of our lower
natures and the decadent corruption and
otherwise
uh profane aspects of our of the paper
clip maximizer in which we live
to further the process of converting
this all into paper clips
that's so beautiful this is the problem
that i see
it's less a problem of sort of like
everything's hunky-dory but we
accidentally create you know terminator
2 or something like that
it's more like it's all part of this of
a reciprocal narrowing that we call
civilization and that we're living
within and we need to actually find our
way out of that in general
this is jonathan pedro welcome to the
symbolic world
[Applause]
i think like one of the things that i
think is going to be important in this
conversation is that
is that it's going to be
when i listen to jordan when i listen to
you speak sometimes i don't understand
what you're saying and i think
part of it is just terminology you have
a whole set of of terms that are
different from the ones that i use and
i've learned to i've learned to
to know john's terms and so i kind of
understand what when he says something i
know i kind of have a background to what
he said it's what he's saying whereas
you sometimes i hear you say something
and you and the conversation continues
and i'm like i didn't i didn't get like
i didn't understand what he's referring
to there so i think that we'll have to
be like at least you have to be generous
with me in this conversation sometimes
i'll stop you and say i don't know what
that means like i don't know what that
what that term means
well maybe i can't even even broaden it
my sense as i've been contemplating this
conversation is that we'll actually want
to be consciously moving quite slowly
uh because the thing that we're dealing
with is um
in some sense the most esoteric thing
possible
um
and
uh language itself isn't going to be an
adequate tool for addressing it
yeah that makes sense
so we've got to uh listen to each other
but follow the logos so that's going to
be
it's going to require all of our
virtuosity and virtue um
so
and so i guess i mean this conversation
i guess was sparked
by a discussion jordan that you had with
a few other people on rebel wisdom about
egregors and i think that the notion of
agriguards has been kind of floating
around i've been seeing different people
uh talk about it also because everybody
seems to be reading tomberg's
meditations on the tarot right now which
i'm reading at this moment and he also
talks about egregors as well and this
this spawned several articles on my
website from people that are kind of in
my mind space
uh you know talking about my the way i
talk about
higher beings and challenging it trying
to figure it out and so that's what at
least sparked my interest in having a
conversation about this which is to try
to understand agency at
transpersonal levels what does that mean
is there agency is there consciousness
can we perceive it you know how do we
participate in that
that's the thing that interests me very
much these days and i think it also i
mean john i know it's part of your work
and jordan with that conversation i saw
that you were definitely thinking about
it so
yes well i would say something like um
this question this category question
simultaneously is um
radically under considered in the
um i would create maybe conventional
wisdom within the sort of the
to the degree to which people are
thinking about how to act in the world
very few of those who have an agency in
a sort of material sense at least
consider this category properly or even
at all in most cases
and to the degree to which this category
has any degree of reality it's obviously
significantly impactful so that's a high
asymmetry
and
i've i think frankly maybe of the three
of us been
more along the lines of the mainstream
meaning up until relatively recently
these sorts of notions popped into my
head but i didn't think about them that
much
and then over the past
five to seven years
i increasingly found myself frankly
obligated to contemplate them more
deeply
and so
i'm coming in as a as a bit much more of
a novice i would imagine um in the
category so you can see i'm maybe
representing almost more of an audience
than a
um contributor but
motivated participatory audience
so i mean where i'm coming at this i
mean i've recently published three
papers with dan chiappi and you know
important academic journals uh really
exploring distributed cognition that's
what it's called in forty cockside this
has been talked about deeply in four e
cogs eye
especially the work of chalmers and
clark for a long time ed hutchins work
on cognition in the wild where he talked
about uh the distributed cognition the
dynamical system that navigates a ship
was it in the 80s uh
so this topic has been
part of the part of the the one of the
fourth e is extended and part of calling
uh
cognition extended is exactly the idea
of distributed cognition and dynamical
systems
i think we should pay more attention
to
that uh
very often fine-grained working out
around it and it's and it is being
worked out uh one way i would recommend
right away is that i would i would
challenge the word agrigore which i
think is a bad
term an infilicidous term
in that it already mis-frames the
phenomena we are trying to talk about
because it's based on the idea of
aggregation
uh which is a completely bottom-up
understanding of the phenomena that's
what aggregation means i put a bunch of
i draw a bunch of things together and
something emerges from them and the
problem with that purely bottom up model
is it only gets half of the story uh
that is actually the case in distributed
cognition this is something jonathan and
i have talked about and jordan you and i
have talked about it to a degree too
to the degree to which these things take
on a life of their own and are properly
understood as hyper agents that's my
term or spirits that's uh jonathan's
term and i'm not using that term
prejudicially at all um
they we have to
really understand uh the top-down
element in them uh from the very
beginning
and
i think
the degree to which we try to have these
these these purely either bottom up or
top-down models of these kind of
phenomena which are are the great
temptations this degree to which we are
following into
a
we're starting off on the wrong foot in
a fundamental way i i tend to prefer the
term hyperagent
or which is analogous to morton's idea
of hyper objects and so it has already
has a good provenance and it captures
the discourse around the agency of the
collective intelligence
found within distributed cognition those
are the three terms i would like to put
at the front
hyperagency collective intelligence
distributed cognition and put them
within a framework that is not just
bottom-up but also equally top down
so that's my first proposal
my sense is i'm coming at it almost in
the direction of a blind man feeling the
landscape
and trying to notice what the different
things are in the landscape and i'm not
quite sure what what's there
and it seems like there's probably a
number of distinct kinds of things that
are not all the same
but it might be useful to discern the
distinctions and
um
[Music]
and some sense of like would you call it
the not the
bestiary what's a collection of beings
called
definitely don't want to call it
pantheon but you know what i'm saying a
collection a beast theory or a taxonomy
yeah taxonomy yeah
and so i i think that the way that i
because i've been thinking a lot about
this agrigore and also i've been
provoked and kind of challenged by my
own
the people that
that follow what i'm doing and they're
thinking in similar terms as i as i am
uh and one of the things that they've
noticed is that there are
certain let's say there are collective
beings or like hyper agents the way that
john talks about that seem to
uh have
let's say have more logos that seem to
be teleologically structured let's say
the the navigation of a ship for example
so the navigation of a ship will have a
clear hierarchy and there'll be a
captain who will let's say
be the top of the of the way that the
direction that it's going he's going to
manage the others but they're all
working together and paying attention to
the same telos and so they're able to
function as a as a body you know but
there are also versions of these beings
that seem to be something like headless
and this is what some of my my friends
have pointed to me pointed out to me and
that they seem to be more uh
they seem to pop up and disappear and so
you see that the the type of being that
jordan was talking about in his
discussion about these these weird
morality codes that rise up online and
then start to manage the way that people
act
they seem to be these headless beings
but they are they do have they act upon
the group
they have
positive power and so they look like
that's why there's something of a
monstrous effect and that's why
these people we're gonna i'm gonna have
a conversation with them as well
soon but that why they said maybe the
term egregor is good for these types of
of manifestations which are these like a
mob for example that they did swerving
and then people pop up like if you look
at tiananmen square is a great example
of this when when it was happening you'd
have you had this mob of people and then
all of a sudden a leader would pop up
and then people kind of start to follow
that leader for in like an hour and then
someone else would scream somewhere else
and then people would just like be
moving from head to head and they
couldn't find uh clear direction and and
really is like this so it does have a
kind of agency but i mean you would say
something like a demonic agency it's
it's breaking it's it doesn't have a
clear telos let's say
that's where i'd want to challenge it i
think i like i like the distinction and
i now see how i would respond i'd say if
you want to reserve aggregor to those
things those processes that are
self-organizing but are not auto poetic
then that is exactly where the the
boundary of agency is lost
tornado is self-organizing and that to
me is what's happening in tiananmen
square you're having a social tornado
but it is not auto-poetic in that it
does not self-organize in order to seek
out the conditions that produce promote
and protect its own existence whereas i
take it that hyper agencies do so an
example of a hyper agency that clearly
does this is a bureaucracy bureaucracies
in fact often become totally just
self-perpetuating entities that have
been sell they self-organize for this
t-loss but the autopoetic element takes
over and sometimes to horrific degrees
that's in kafka right and so right so i
i'm now seeing a continuum but to me the
the line uh where we ascribe agency is
precisely the line of where the
self-organization has passed properly
into being autopoetic and when there is
no evidence for autopilosis we should
not ascribe agency and when uh what we
can we can we can ascribe sophistic very
sophisticated self organization and if
that's what people want to point to with
the term aggregator then i think it's a
good term for that phenomena and i'm
willing to accept that correction but
for me i i'm interested in uh the
capacity
for reality to produce hyper agents
because they to me
have a significance for our understand
we have always understood our agency in
relationship to some kind of hyper
agency to me i think that's part of your
point jonathan right human beings have
always understood ourselves in terms of
hyper agents and so i think the current
discovery of hyper agency has a
spiritual potential and significance
that the discovery of just these so of
social self-organization does not have
okay let me throw something in that just
came up and i'm not sure this is a good
idea but it occurs to me
that to the degree to which
this conversation
has a capacity to be an embodiment or a
manifestation of one of these kinds of
beings yes
that would be the
self-referentially proper way to guide
its directionality yes
what being is endeavoring to express
itself to these particular humans so we
can take it as a applied experiment
experiment
excellent um
something that i noticed that this
particular one seems to have as a
orientation is precision
and as you were talking about the
distinction between a
tornado
and let's say something else
i wanted to get very very close because
that line is actually a very
subtle line yes right if i zoom in at
the edge of a tornado
there actually is a shift
in
the probability
of brownian motion
at the event horizon
of the causal structures
of air molecules that is what produces
the
uh
auto catalytic characteristic yes
distinction between autocatalytic and
autopoetic yes
the fine point
and i'd be interested to see if it's
worth spending time trying to get down
there although it is of course a
tremendous rabbit hole that may
implicate the whole question
well um i don't want to trespass on
jonathan but i i since i think the
question is directed towards me uh for
me
um
the
auto
and this is of course you know what
kaufman says it's it might be necessary
but it's not sufficient for life
but because an auto catalytic process
right is in some sense perpetuating
itself but it is nevertheless not
seeking out the conditions
that have to
uh obtain and so my evidence for that is
tornadoes will move on to terrain that
immediately destroys them and as
jonathan was saying the
self-organization is starting to
coalesce into you know something that
might do something around this leader
and then it shifts to this leader and
then it shifts to this leader right and
so it's not there is not there is no
there is no
well to my mind there is not enough top
down and that's why i wanted to
emphasize in in
the aggregor i'll use that term now to
refer to these
social social self-organization
social self-organizations if that's okay
um there's not enough top down to
attribute cognition
um because
i take it that what we're trying to
talk about when we're talking about
things like when we're invoking terms
like spirit
um or what i try to look like hyperagent
is we have something that
has the has a capacity
to not just self-perpetuate but to
self-promote and self-protect
and that in that sense we want to sort
of equally attribute cognition and
something like a life
to it
okay so me the other thing i'd like to
bring into this what you're saying john
is
what would be the difference between
let's say so we have the notion of of a
being that
is properly organized towards the talos
and structures itself hierarchically in
a way that that seems to give it agency
right so then we have these these
momentary beings that kind of shift from
one
one way to the other and don't seem to
be able to do that and then you have
something what i would call something
like parasitic processes yes yes right
so let's say i see that you more easily
within
within within oh let's say the mob so
the mob is a good example like at a
social level and that an addiction would
be a good example at a personal level
where you have a process that is
self-perpetuating that has all the
mechanisms to preserve itself but then
is can ultimately be the demise of the
the structure that holds it together can
ultimately kind of break can kill you
like so you can have an addictive
pattern within you that is doing all
these things but then it ultimately
could act against against the body
that's holding it together
it's funny as you were saying that i've
immediately thought of parasitic
processing so i think i'm right i'm
really catching your perspective i hope
yeah i think i i think
um the idea of
uh
uh of something like a self-organizing
process
that
um is parasitic
and and but is nevertheless
self-destructive
of what we might call it substrate i'm
trying to use terms very neutrally here
um
yeah i i think that's right
um
but
i mean since i coined the term with leo
i i guess i could speak to its
provenance the intent of parasitic
processing is it's actually something
that is destroying agency that's one of
its defining features it it it it
insinuates itself into the agency of
well in the case we originally talking
about of an individual cognizer takes on
a life of its own but but at the expense
of the agency that it is dependent upon
um and so for me
um
that's
i i think what that calls for then i
mean i i feel what's happening is we're
being called to like a continuum in the
taxonomy we've got agrigores and then we
have hyper agents and now there's this
in-between thing um
and i yeah
to me it doesn't it doesn't cross the
line the threshold into hyper agency
because
uh it's like an addiction it's
ultimately uh it's a twist in the
potential for agency that is being
actualized as the self-destruction of
agency if that makes any sense yeah well
one of the reasons why i'm using i'm
trying to bring that up is just because
i
i'm also trying to account for the
iconography let's say that is one of the
reasons why demons are represented the
way they are like if you look at the way
demons are represented they're always
represented as hybrid monsters that is
they're represented in a way that they
have no definite identity but they can
nonetheless
act on you and they act on you in a
manner that wants to like you said john
to destroy your agency to destroy your
your being basically they want the
humans ultimately want to feed off of
you until you die and so they're
actually represented visually if you
look at the way they're represented in
in medieval art in a way that seems to
represent what this problem that we're
talking about so they're like they're
they're egregors in a way because
they're like this mismatch of
of uh beings you know they're like a
fish mixed with the with the human mixed
with you know with the tail and all
these weird things but then it also is
able to act upon you and in a way that's
violent right they're sticking forward
with you they're they're they're
basically torturing you ultimately
i like where this is going i like that
how we're getting this
this articulation of
uh of the continuum that is
trying to be birthed in the taxonomy i
like this a lot
so let me throw some more
parameters or um
what you call that sort of like edges
shape
one is
something like closure uh thermodynamics
closed system disconnections
rabbit right something has happened a
discontinuity has occurred the physical
body and the components that made up
that physical body are now subject to a
completely different regime of dynamics
right they've now become
thermodynamic and characteristic
in fact a more fundamental notion i
think of parasitic process which is
there's a gradient of possibility or a
stored capacity that has been developed
up by the organic being which is now a
feedstock for a completely different set
of regimes that are in fact from in
relationship with the with the rabbit
artifact bottoms up right they're
bacteria and predators and parasites and
whatnot they're going to decompose that
stored energy which is living precisely
in the gap between what was at one point
a
autopoetic process and is now
transitioned okay that's one
two
um
yeah the
the um how would we say the the
the confusion that arises
when something of that sort
let's just go with the bunny that died
for a moment
happens to be made up of human beings
aha
the difference between a tornado and the
mob
is the tornado it was made up of air
molecules
and the affordance of air molecules for
engaging in cognition in a meaningful
way is quite small
whereas the mob is made up of human
beings
and so the affordance of human beings
for engaging in cognition is relatively
quite high
and so we may ascribe to the mob a level
of cognition that is in fact not
properly happening at the mob
but is what happens when something that
was alive is now in this parasitic
process dynamic but its sub components
are in fact fully functioning cognitive
agents and that creates a little bit of
a confusion about what's actually going
on
oh i see
that that's really interesting that's
really interesting
yes
so there's a you're saying there's a
great temptation for
we have to be very careful of a category
in a classical sense a category mistake
um yes misapplying between the species
and the genus yes and if you take the
notion of short-term and long-term or or
what's it called global optimum and
local optimum yeah and apply that
against the
choice linking landscape of a cognitive
agent so let's go with a mobster
effectively what's happening when we
refer to the notion of disconnection or
separation is we're reducing the scope
of self that is actually in in the
context of making choices
what what had been a larger self a
greater being is now made up of a very
uh field of smaller solves that are
making choices in the basis of a much
smaller scope of capacity which is their
local optima
because they're orienting towards local
optima they're in fact degrading the
landscape that had included a global
optimum
right it's the whole wholeness of the
autopoetic beingness
but because these are in fact functional
cognitive agents there's a substantial
amount of activity that's going on that
looks in fact in fact is
cognition right so they're
shaping the landscape in a potent way so
really looking closely at what's going
on inside that gap gives us a lot of
insight in fact by the way it may be
like a a 10 000 year long thermodynamic
process
that is constantly eating up
these the feedstock that emerges in the
context of ordinary human
uh how humans come together into
wholeness and what is possible in the
context of humanness as a
source for parasitic process and every
time that source comes together
endeavors to reach a more whole
basis it actually provides a niche for
this parasitic process this goes back to
your demons i think
that's brilliant so that you
if i hear you right you're proposing
that the demonic is actually a case
where there's a degradation of the hyper
agency into parasitic processing and we
can understand parasitic processing in
terms of how it's undermining the
cognition of the individual agents did i
understand you correctly certainly a
piece of it yes
well if i'm missing an important please
please say please tell me
uh something along the lines of the um
how do you say this
the notion of tornado so the idea of
there being a
an eddy or a standing wave or a
strictly causal dynamic that provides a
niche where this degradation process
holds the relationship in kind of a
medium um
yeah there's a
how do we say this this is i haven't
quite got it like i can almost feel it
but there's something at the level of
the top down
that has to and then the level of the
bottom up and then the relationship that
feels like it's all part of the context
well let me try maybe something that was
missing out of what i just said that i'm
hearing you say
is you were talking about like there's
something like in in
right my point was the aggregator is
completely bottom up
right that's what i was arguing and then
we've got the demonic and what i heard
you saying is the demonic is now a
disproportionate
relationship between the top down and
the bottom up in which the balance that
is found within the hyper agent is being
lost because
right
the top down is now in a
self-destructive process of undermining
the individual cognition of the of the
component people that's what i well
that's what i heard you saying like like
there's a top down right instead of a
balance between the top down and the
bottom up there's uh there's a
misalignment and the top down is now
imposing and infecting the lower
processors so the idea would be
something like let's say the system or
the hyper agent is trying to be too uh
is trying to to fill up too much space
it's not leaving enough because you need
a little messiness yes on the edge for
things to to work and so
if you if you're they're not careful it
will create it or give the opportunity
for these
give reason for these parasitic
processes to kind of to kind of appear
and
and uh
but i'm not i don't see i can kind of
see it i can see it i can see it
mythologically
sorry this is my problem like i think in
storage so i can see it mythologically
which is that a good example is you know
in um
in the bible there are these laws about
how to till your field you kill your
field but you have to leave the corner
of the field untiled
and you have to leave that for the
stranger so you have to leave it for the
processes that aren't part of your hyper
agent you could say you kind of have to
leave a little bit of room on the edge
for for a buffer between
but if you're not careful with those
corners
they can
they can start to impose themselves if
you try to till them too much then they
revet they they come back like a revenge
they come back like uh but and if you if
you if you leave them too big then they
also kind of they tend to want to eat
your system i don't know if that makes
sense like you have to be careful
because the small system no hyper agent
can fill up
all of its
like the world isn't the world has all
this chaos on the edge so you can't fill
up the world with the system it will
always leave a remainder so so
the way that's coming to my first of all
what came to mind is kafka precisely
because what happens in the bureaucracy
is it becomes a parasitic process that
drains
sovereignty and individual cognition
away that's the horror of the kafka of
the cough gas right that the there's
been the
the like so bureaucracies are this is
max weber they're supposed to be
bottom-up error signal and then top-down
prediction right sort of mimicking
aspects of but what happens right is you
get the bureaucracy just being the
top-down discharging of blame and not
any uh upward tick of error correction
and you get that you get the horror
right because the the line of
communication has just become
unidirectional
yeah and a bureaucracy that's too strong
will produce corruption it will
necessarily produce corruption that's
how it that's what happens in a
bureaucracy that is too that is too
pervasive exactly exactly and so what
what comes to mind is is karsa's idea
where
the hyper agent is oriented towards the
infinite game right whereas the
parasitic process is engaged in a in a
finite kind of game because what it's
trying to do right is get some sort of
final closure
right because it
because it's i'm sorry i'm stumbling it
because because it's parasitic because
it's self-destructive it can't be an
infinite game player do you get what i'm
trying to get at it it can't whereas
leaving the corners of the field is that
there's going to be stuff beyond the
game and we're going to have to one of
the things we have to do as we play the
game is change the rules by how which we
play the game because it will be the
stranger right
right but the finite game says no no no
that's the top down bureaucracy we can
encompass this completely
and when you look at parasitic
processing within individuals what
what's typically happening is is that is
is reciprocal narrowing
until they get to like it can't be any
other way than this it can't be any
other way than this
sorry i'm just trying to
like rock what you said but i got i got
a powerful sense of right that
there there's an inability of a
parasitic processing the demonic i mean
but this this is cl you know this
jonathan this is like dionysus evil is
ultimately totally parasitic on the good
right it it it pretends to help itself
existence but it can't actually play the
infinite game so you but if you think
think of it like in a person in terms of
let's say a fast binge pattern right
where someone is on a diet a diet binge
pattern where someone tries to make
create a top-down pattern of being in
themselves where they're they're like
i'm going to lose weight i'm going to do
this and do that they make it so strict
that the opposite happens because a
parasitic process sets itself up then
you find yourself at two in the morning
eating a tub of ice cream and it's like
that is and you know it's destroying you
but it's like there's something else
taking over your will
yeah because what happens is instead of
a dynamic right between bottom up and
top down you're getting a vacillation
you get the top down
right the the kafka s and then you get
the bottom up
explosion of impulsivity that's the
binging i lose all agency and then i
right and and you you're getting that
going back and that's typically what's
happening in parasitic processing
so it comes up for me there and i'm so
noticing two things one is
i
how do i say this right symbolically i
heard
john reference the notion of changing
the game
and so with la that landed for me was
perhaps a orientation or an invitation
to shift the game
that we're engaging in
uh and i noticed that i felt something
how do i say strong perhaps or certain
clarity
when jonathan was orienting us in the
direction of the mythological
part of the invitation i would say is to
shift more into a mythological
poetic artistic
religious mystery mystic mystic mode
uh
okay the other one that came up as i was
myself doing that
was i was the word golem came in
and it spoke to something like um
there's a kind of part
in humans we might call this the mind
or the ego
that has this one of his characteristics
both a
a capacity and in some sense a
propensity to take itself as the whole
so this is that
that thing where you don't actually have
relationship with with proper
relationship with wholeness and i'm
wondering if this is that
that that delicate balance of the the
four-cornered field
um you know the
the cylinder charybdis on either side of
that very delicate balance
but actually
it takes itself and presents itself as
representing the whole but in fact it
certainly can't and this is what gets
you in real trouble like that's the that
feels like the
two two sides of the coin one side of
the coin is the the real actuality of
the lived delicate balance of
relationship with
the actual lived whole
and
particular i'm not sure if this is a
commonplace thing i think it may in fact
be a precisely human thing but we'll see
the the challenge or the risk of a
particular aspect of
human holes again i'll say things like
mind and ego that that will endeavor to
present themselves as in fact actually
being
a whole
um and therefore get in the way right
and this is that sort of mob problem
like the demonic capacity something like
that so there's a bunch of things there
that maybe can we can play with well
there's definitely let's say in the
image of the demonic hierarchy you have
the devil as being as pride being the
sin of the devil that is definitely
that is there the idea is that what the
what the the devil says is i am
i am god right i i am god and so comes
into conflict with the whole because he
wants to be
the totality of all things in in himself
let's say and not participate in
something bigger than him and that is
what leads to
the the the two so in terms of what
we're talking about in terms of the flip
between one side and the other saint
maximus the confessor he talks about he
talks about sins of the right hand and
sins of the left hand and he says the
first sin is always the sin of the right
hand that is its pride self-sufficiency
all of these types of sins and then
those secretly lead to sins of the left
hand which are you know passions falling
apart you know you know all these
thoughts that you can't control and so
you have this this movement from one to
the other but it is rooted in the the
idea of
not let's say a being not participating
in a greater whole but wanting to just
exist
as itself like as this kind of self
perpetuating thing
so so that i think this is a good move
because
participating like what's the
participatory relationship right and so
you know you know 11s makes the famous
distinction between totality which is
what the bureaucracy is trying to do or
what the passion is trying to do also
and infinity
and the right and so the totality is the
idea that this can be this can be
grasped the speed closed upon
right
whereas the living thing is the has the
proper relationship to infinity in the
sense that the living thing has a
capacity for evolution that the
parasitic processing thing doesn't have
right like this this is the sense i'm
getting in fact from maximus i'm reading
him right now if you if
if i'll use mythological language as
jordan invited us if god was to
completely remove
he can't i get it but if he were right
and the demons were allowed to run
completely free they would disappear in
an instant
right because they would reciprocally
narrow to nothing they don't actually
they do not have a in fact the defining
feature of them i would put it to you is
they're incapable of evolution they're
incapable of right
that movement that is constitutive of
life which is the participation in
infinity without ever claiming to have a
totality
and so
the thing i see in the mob is exactly
that feature
right it may be self-perpetuating and so
therefore it's different than the pure
agrigore but it can't evolve or i would
put it this way if it starts to evolve
it precisely ceases being
a mob and becomes a proper hyper agent
so
right and just just to hold that little
piece right there is that there's a um
[Music]
just a that thing i brought in earlier
about the fact that we don't want to be
confused so the mob
right we have a very very nice term
actually the distinct between evolution
and development yes development is the
exploration of a potential that is
already present in a closed domain yes
yes so so the mob in fact can develop
meaning it has a period of time whereby
it can in fact expose a novelty that was
already imparted into the reality that
it was that it was at the moment of his
being yes without actually being
connected to a wholeness and therefore
is incapable of evolution right yes yes
yeah okay
jonathan this doesn't this resonate i
mean at least in some deep ways i mean
like i said i'm doing lectio divine on
both dionysus and maximus right now and
that's right and i both had sections
both where they're wrestling with right
the existence of evil and they're both
making the argument
that you know evil is kind of pure
self-destructiveness
and like like jordan says it has a
capacity for development uh because it's
not completely self-existent although it
pretends to be yeah
right but
if it was to un if it was completely
unconstrained by the love of god yeah it
wouldn't it wouldn't it
would it would actually like completely
self-destruct
like i don't think i'm imposing that on
them when i'm no no no i think you're
right yeah so a good i think so the way
that i like to think about it at least
so would be something like the
constitutive elements of an agrigore
let's say they're they're these
parasitic
patterns parasitic structures but they
have
they have the they could have the
possibility of being more than what they
are it's just that they aren't they
they're they're they're self they're
looking at themselves and it's it's
called devolving because of that so so
an addiction is a good example so
everything
is based on a true desire which could
lead you into something more but because
it closes itself off and then then acts
as this weird self-existent being then
it then it becomes parasitical and tends
to destroy the higher agent
so now we have to bring in the notion of
selling your soul
[Laughter]
the addiction captures
the actual vitality of a living being
yes and it
enslaves it whips right it drives that
living being it actually will extinguish
it but in the meantime it will actually
tap into whatever degree of evolution
that living being actually still has
left in it
so if you imagine sort of your classic
let's go with jim morris and somebody
who i have a
sort of a connection with you know a
vital
genius connected to wholeness in a
particular way
and written by a demon
that pushed the being into a
self-destructive ex
look at local optima
extraction
of what was available in terms of a
short-term burning brightness that
generated a an energetic flow of of
capacity that was extracted by the demon
until of course the underlying host died
at which point
the demon also evaporates or in this
case has to find a new a new host
yeah
um
and many of us may in fact be associated
with that so there's a very interesting
one that's now we're getting to a very
interesting place to begin exploring
what that looks like
um
but i think you're right the idea of
selling your soul is that's exactly what
it is it's like i mean you could say
that every time that you
see a good in itself
or that you try to attach yourself to a
good in itself that isn't leading you to
better higher goods that isn't
that isn't placing you in a system of
higher goods let's say then you are
somewhat selling your soul or you're
letting your soul be captured
by something which will feed off of it
anything anytime you you profane the
sacred you're selling your soul
yeah and so you can understand like it's
a
a country for example
could have that that problem where they
get caught up in one specific aspect of
what it is to be
a country and then they they
kind of revolve around that and then it
captures the soul of the
of the country so
and then it ends up it can end up just
devouring it you i think you saw that in
in communist countries um
and i think you probably see it now
let's say
in america you can see how entertainment
has become let's say this massive weird
parasitic thing that is that is
devouring everybody's attention
uh and is in some way blinding them to
higher goods in which they can
participate it's kind of capturing the
soul of a of even a country
and there are different forms of that i
think
so
it's the demonic in this sense
sorry i'll i will you two can keep
exploring the mythological i'll try and
play that game but i keep coming back to
the biological maybe we're trying to
actually get uh bios and mythos and
logos to talk to each other here um but
um
like the metaphor that's coming to mind
for these kinds of things is like like a
virus like that right um
as
all right um
like the i i'm trying all the viruses
can evolve so that's where the analogy
breaks down but i'm trying to get almost
something like a computer virus is what
i want um that can infect and spread and
replicate uh but it is completely
dependent asymmetrically it's
asymmetrically dependent but it can't
ever become a bonafide you know uh
program that does anything useful in the
world um
because i'm trying to get at right
the reason i bring it up is because it's
a there's a real debate and i don't mean
like just academics doing their typical
hair splitting there's a real debate
about whether or not viruses have agency
that's why i'm bringing up that as the
analogy because they it and there's a
real debate about whether or not they're
actually alive precisely because they
they're sitting on that boundary right
uh right between right they sit right on
this gray line between uh agency and
non-agency and between living and
non-lemming
and and
and
i'm
i feel like we're wrestling with a
deeply analogous problem with
the the demonic or whatever we want to
call this this meddling thing is right
is it perhaps also that
because for me the notion of hyperagency
i think is very well developed
and i think the notion of aggregation is
very well developed you can cybernetic
systems etc etc right but this
intermediary thing it seems like it's
difficult for us precisely because it's
falling between
the right the living and the non-living
the agentic and the non-agentic like a
virus
right and
and i'm just wondering if if we're
struggling because
we are we are bringing categories to
bear on it that it
definitionally eludes
right
like i'm just like no i think i think i
think you're right but i think that your
understanding of in between
is extremely important right and if i if
i bring about the image of the chimera
like the way that the chimera is
represented
the demon is represented as a chimera
and so this is the in-between space this
is the problem of the in between space
the problem of transitions right all
this all this issue and so i think that
this is what the virus represents you by
the way john you know that jacques
in a famous interview said that
everything that he's ever done is about
a virus everything that he's ever done
is about virology because exactly of
that point which is that the virus is is
a viva the virus is a living dead it's
like a zombie in a way like this in
between
character
because we and then when we focus on it
it it tends to deconstruct the the the
identities it tends to actually kind of
devour parasitically the different
identity that it's attached to
yes yes i've forgotten that but i i
thank you for reminding me i was
thinking of uh
burrows that language is a virus from
outer space um i was thinking which was
i guess is very deridian
also but thank you for that yeah that
that i do knew i did know that but i had
forgotten that that's a fantastic
uh remembering yes uh there is so i
think that one of the reasons why we're
seeing
this now is that on the one hand we have
a
system let's say a system of control
that control of information which is the
internet which is also the states the
states moving into things like digital
identity and digital control so we have
these systems happening so we can notice
this this top down thing that is coming
down strong but at the same time we also
have this deconstructive mode in the
culture this idea of destroying of
breaking down identities of
these parasitic behaviors and so i think
that it's those two extremes happening
at the same time are probably possibly
the thing that is making people able to
perceive these hyper agents again which
because they're you can see they're
pressing down on us we can kind of see
it it happening in a way that you know
because you think like who controls
twitter for example
he's like well no one actually controls
twitter
they get taken up by these ideological
things that come back down but it's like
you couldn't point to one person and say
this this person controls like say the
narrative right now it's it's happening
organically for sure
but but that was always the case
to my point language is a virus from
outer space that was always the case for
language nobody controls it nobody runs
it there's nobody in charge of it yet
right but it evolves and it changes and
it has a life of its own in powerful
ways we are all asymmetrically dependent
on the languages that we know right in
powerful ways um i think i think the
point that jonathan is making is
something like because we're in a moment
where
a whole category of hyperagents are in
the process of dying inelegantly
um
it's easier to notice that that's what's
happening
right the the sort of the the
the bunny is no longer just sort of it
no longer maybe it's no longer maybe
sleeping right the rot has set in
quite significantly there's a certain
stench
and a certain
awareness that if you touched it maybe
something bad would happen to you you
don't want to eat it anymore it's
definitely not a healthy thing to be
connected with
simultaneously
the
kind of the game is a foot to see what
new kinds of hyper agents might want to
step in
and integrate us so neatly into their
body
um and so both you know the the sort of
decaying dead body of the hyper agents
of the past
sort of collapsing titanic like into the
ocean and maybe pulling us down with
them is present very viscerally um as
are all the various kinds of the
previous simplicities of the ways that
you would go about solving basic
problems in life like going to the
grocery store are no longer obvious and
simple and so shit's [ __ ] up and you
have to think about it oh [ __ ] i have to
think about it what's happening oh and
it kind of pushes the mind into a
greater greater awareness of what's
happening
and because this novelty is there
there's both a an awareness of the of
the moment of geez if we don't make some
of us but don't make choices in a
certain direction then we'll be brought
into a new kind of thing
probably kicking and screaming um
and also
when that was the time if we would like
to have something be slightly different
you couldn't have done it in 1977 there
was no chance of that but now you can
because the space of transitions upon us
that kind of thing so i think those are
bringing into the surface this awareness
and the mythopoetic is activating it
within us say hey guys this is sort of
one of those times
i agree with that i think that's a good
point so thank you for that
i guess i would want to say i would
that the point i was trying to bring out
i think is then needs to be brought into
proper relation which is i wanted to
indicate that it has always been the
case that there have been things that
nobody's in charge of language culture
etc etc
and that we
we have lost
a cognitive cultural grammar in order to
talk about them
that is also part of the problem i agree
with you jordan you know i do that we
are now in a time of accelerating rated
complexification um i i i i like this
almost mythological idea of hyper agents
becoming zombies
right this is a term actually used of
certain distributed cognitive systems
right like the the zombies in between
the the viral entities um
and and they're infecting us and that
makes us aware of them but i i also
think we've lost a way of
talking and thinking
and conceiving
of
the hyper agents
that is also part of the problem
um that and
right um
i think it that
for many people and
this is no backhanded criticism to
jonathan who i consider an important
friend right but for many people
they are not willing to take up the
ancient language the ancient languages
that's i keep coming back to language as
a metaphor here the
ancient languages by which
these hyper agents were properly related
to
um and
and lived with if i can put and lived
through
and so i i i don't deny everything you
said i i that there's something
happening here but i also think there
there is also an impoverishment on on
our side of our capacity to enter into a
proper receptivity
of these entities that is also making
um everything much worse
sorry that that ended up there yeah if i
wanted to monopolize the game of hyper
agency
then i would impoverish the language of
humanity
yes
yes
yes yeah and there's also something
which i think is happening which is
which is also part of this which is that
as we notice i mean let's be honest like
as we watch christianity die let's say
one of the things that's happening is
that there it's leave it's giving the
space for these competing
hyper agents to appear like jordan was
talking about basically you have all
these
these
beings
rushing in
and now fighting
amongst each other to figure out who's
going to take over
um
aren't they all often just zombie
christianities yeah that's right well
that's what i think that what i was
coming to is the idea of antichrist like
i i think that this is something it
seems like christians had perceived at
the outset that the idea that in the
moment of its death or in the moment
that christianity would
would would fall apart like there would
be this spirit of antichrist which would
appear which would be a strange
remainder a strange parasitic version of
christianity that would that would
appear
and would kind of take over the space
and so even if you look at the like
weird neopagan type things that are
coming in they're all framed as
strangely anti-christian at the same
time you know so you
at least in the west for sure i mean i
don't know about in another place but in
the west this is what seems to be
happening but then now the thing is that
now these small little beings are
appearing and manifesting themselves and
people are noticing them
and the fact that a lot of people
haven't noticed these beings before
let's say
means that now they're fascinated by
them
like they're fascinated by them like i
even like i think the whole psychedelic
thing a lot of it has to do with that
it's like people
they they they take these psychedelics
they encounter these intelligences and
they become fascinated no matter what it
is that they encounter they have no way
to they don't discern
these beings that they're encountering
they just encounter them and there seems
to be something of that going on which
is like
if i can have a
you know people join these little weird
subcultural groups and become extremely
passionate about about it because they
are looking for hyper agency they're
looking for ways to participate in in
common stories and in common but there's
no there is
there is no there is no way for it to
they all appear these parasitic things
and they're all devouring people's
attention and you know whether it be
like star wars jedi culture or or crazy
you know
a political activism like all of it is
the same it's like these little
parasitic processes that are taking up
people's attention and driving them
towards
separation at least like
for sure we should throw baudrillard
into the mix we brought his buddy
jacques we might as well bring in
beaudry art
um
simulations
uh simulations in simulacra right
but i would i would like to point out
maybe two things to help uh expand one
is
yeah i'll say it's actually two parts of
the same thing
uh i don't know that we we
are
are
really properly
in relationship with
the degree to which humans
have been living
in
these sort of dead decaying
um
no longer wholesome contexts
i i would say something like and i'm
gonna make this proposal
i would say something like 98
95 85 of all of history has been the
history of human beings
being in this game of being like in the
mob meaning
the the thing they are not living a
living whole
being system they are in fact
participating in
the development the exploration of the
sort of
uh
except extraction of the decaying body
of something that they're part of which
lasts hundreds of thousands of years at
an arc
so we've been living in a period of
momentary eruptions
of
i think guess the word probably is
properly spirit in some very specific
sense
which then provides a a temporary of
course in human arc hundreds of years or
thousands of years temporary sort of
body to be slowly decayed
um
and that as a consequence we actually
get very confused right we we mistake
the game of playing mob
mobster for the game of actually being
in connection with wholesome reality
um because our metaphors and our
references are still pulling examples of
the same [ __ ] thing just maybe at a
larger scope or a different period if
it's death and here here i'll call out
specifically two guys who i i've got a
lot of reference to one is carol quigley
and others peter turchen
who talk about the rise and fall of
civilizations
and and quickly i think did the best job
because of the period of time when he
was writing which was uh
you know when his civilization is born
let's go with rome
on the on the palatine hills just barely
pushing back against a uh the celtic
invasion
there's a
a point at which a certain kind of let's
say codes or generator function a moment
of evolution occurs in a period of
absolute
uh
crisis
this thing creates what he called the
expansive principle that once that is
born there's almost like the whole story
of rome for a thousand years is locked
in at that point you have this arc
through which it deploys it develops it
explores the space that is born more or
less in a in a generation
and it expands to the degree to which
that expansive principle gives it power
the ability to extract power and
concentrate it on itself it just expands
and of course it explores the edges and
the fringes because it's using human
beings as cognitive agents and it
becomes a sort of demonic principle
expanding on the backs of those who are
brought in more and more and more into
the body of rome i'm noticing that as a
really interesting metaphor or a
mythopoetic babylon right
but it's already dead right there's a
point at which it will appear by the way
quickly very specifically says when you
think you're in a golden age
you're actually at the point at which
you're eating the seed right that you're
consuming the last vital energy and then
by the time you realize you're in the
decline the civilization is actually
passed into the point of if it's
inevitable death it just may take a
while depending on how much it can
continue to consume right how much can
it eat
you know how much energy was contained
within the reservoir that it did at
stake
and so you know if we imagine that
that's the story right that it's only
actually at the edges right it's only in
moments of true gathering right when
it's when geez when spirit is present
that the upwelling comes but for the
most part for the whole of civilization
we've actually been living in
dead things and we've built the mindset
of parasitism so deeply into our grammar
into our sensibilities that we're going
to have to be extremely careful not to
take a simulation of something that
seems like a really good copy of the
real thing as the real thing
so you've you've you've got a version of
the fall to speak
mythologically
that that's true
right
um so but the thing the question is
so so jordan peterson his
his the way that he talks about it he
says
he says something like you're right
that's how it works but the only way to
do it is to go down into
the belly of the whale
and resurrect your father like because
the problem with the way you're saying
the way that you're saying it is that
you can't manufacture
the kairos moment that will cause the
monumental change you can't manufacture
the moment of expansion
you can't make it up it's something
which kind of which happens
in a in a in a in a revelation you could
say
and so until that revelation happens
it seems like even though
maybe what you're saying is right the
only thing to do
is to try to breathe life into
the the forms that have been given to
you because
or else what or else
i disagree
with or else you have all these like 60s
like cults like you have all these weird
you have all these like little
definitely a bad idea
you know so so what what else then all
right you ready yeah go for it jordan
this is fresh so we're not fresh it's
it's ancient um so i was really thinking
about this after reading that essay
um that was the sort of the precursor of
this conversation
and i was sort of sitting with you know
what my pagia's point of view on
the top down emanation i believe is the
term you used yeah
um
and the thing that kept coming up for me
was a question of creation
and the notion of the moment of creation
and i couldn't help but continually find
myself in a circumstance where i was
finding uh taking the perspective it
just showed it for me as obvious
that the moment of creation is
omnipresent
that is it is not operating in what
would be chrono so it's not operating in
in sort of time as we understand it in
that fashion yeah and so the possibility
of cairo's is always present one does
not manufacture kairos by any stretch of
the imagination but one becomes afforded
to the possibility of perceiving
and playing with the kairos that is
always present
for what it is where what it is right
and that is sort of the beginning of the
end of the story so you separate
definitely don't try to create
a [ __ ] cult right but beyond
comprehension a terrible idea but simply
dancing with the presence of the kairos
that is always present
is the only ethical only proper thing to
do anyway no but i i agree with you that
is i agree in the sense that i agree
that so the way that i would say say it
is that the only thing you can do is
become a saint like that's actually the
only thing you can do the only thing you
can do is
transform your passions transform
yourself transform
your your life and that then you will
become in a way where the christ says
you know become become a tree and then
the bird will land in your branches but
you that has to that has to happen and
so uh and so i agree but there are
different levels of that like there are
different levels of
of kairos let's say they're they're
they're different i can play that role
but i'm not going to
start a new
religion right i can play that role
within the story that has been given to
me and i'm not going so even let's say
even if you take for example christ
he's not making a new thing up
you know what he's doing is he is he is
coming into the judaic tradition and
then you know if you believe what he was
and what he said he's basically
breathing life back into it and showing
us the brightness of what was there like
kind of giving life to something which
was which was given to him and so i
think that that's the only thing we can
do at each of our levels like i think
it's the same even with buddha like
buddha didn't didn't make something up
like he was coming into an aesthetic
tradition he looked he looked at the
different aesthetics and he gathered
that in and then he he transformed it or
represented it in a way which was which
was full let's say um
well i want to respond to that i mean
christianity isn't judaism and buddhism
isn't hinduism right they're right so
there is something that's going on there
i i agree with you we shouldn't be
making
uh a religion um but
i i'm i'm wondering about
like part of morton's point about hyper
objects is that they force us
into a kairos
right like i
i i do think that kairos is upon us uh
and i thought both of you were saying
that earlier there's a sense in which
this we know that something is changing
here because all of these entities are
now
the the plausibility of the existence of
these
entities is now
prominent where it was not 20 or even 15
years ago that seems to me to be an
important marker about the fundamental
levels of our ontology so i do think
that kairos
is upon us but we're not going to direct
it like i don't think that no no we
can't
we but i i i agree i agree i'm trying to
direct it that that is that is exactly
to confuse that is exactly to think it's
all top down neither are we just
supposed to possibly wait that's just
not really
we have to figure out the proper
proportional participation and that's
what i mean by
right
i don't know if we have the language
for that right now for the concepts of
it so
one of the things we can do
is yeah i agree with you
like jordan i i don't disagree with you
know we've been playing the the the sort
of
you know the the the extraction model of
civilization and we can't do that
anymore uh we're at another kairos which
is we're global uh and right we we can't
we can't just have an extraction
mentality
so two things are pushing on us
right we have
the advent
of the reality of the parasitic entities
and the hyper agents
and we have the fact that civilization
now encompasses the globe which had
never had before and so there's no
outside we can't extract and move on we
can't wait
right and so for me
um
like i i want it i want to sort of bring
it back around to
what is it
for us to enter into
proper relationship
with
these hyper agents and these parasitic
agents
such
right
because i mean
i thought that there's a biblical truth
here i thought yes we don't direct the
kairos but our decisions matter to the
kairos that's right
right
and so
how can we
how can we virtuously and with
virtuosity
participate in the largely virtual
medium in which the kairos is presenting
itself
so that
we can discover
the proper relationship
to the the emerging ontology if i can
put it that way that to me
is the question like i i am interested
as a scientist in all of these
ontological questions uh but what what
what comes back to me is
yeah but what's and i think this is what
jordan is saying
and i think maybe you're saying it too
jonathan we're we're out of kairos the
kairos is upon us
right
and
and yes and i get it the historical
kairos is situated against the eternal
kairoz but that's exactly just to put
the question is how do i enter into a
proper relationship
to this emerging ontology
so that
i
can
have some trust that i'm
being virtuous in relationship to it i
mean the problem with
i mean now going to dynamical systems
when they're in criticality
they right small differences matter in
the way that they never mattered before
very small differences like when when
civilization's sort of rumbling around
along the chances that what anything you
or i do can make any difference are very
small but when a system becomes
hypercritical like it is now in both
senses of the word by the way right
small differences can make small actions
can have huge differences so i feel a
tremendous responsibility and the
question that comes from me is okay but
how can i exercise virtuosity grounded
in virtue about this
because for me jordan that's the way of
stepping out of the all-too-human
repetition of the extractor function of
civilization and trying to get to
something more primordial
so
there's a lot to just happened there a
number of different things so let's see
one i would say
ah
if the first thing that popped out very
sharply for me was this this phrase did
not make something up
and i think this is quite important to
really focus on that um
that phrase like to make something up it
it for me it speaks to that notion of
golem right it speaks to that notion of
simulation
uh to be sure
he did not make something up and i would
say even more powerfully to make
something up is precisely this mistake
of mind taking itself to be the whole
so
category error don't do that ever bad
idea
um
and so then it's like what does it mean
to simply be
kind of making choices or to
to act
in right relationship with the kairos in
some sense that's all there is to it
uh so that's all we're talking about
what does it mean to simply make proper
choices in the context of making proper
choices
um
and so
in the to to express the logos
with
humility
and integrity
is very different than to make something
up
yeah
yes yes yes like quite quite the i would
say opposite but not even the word
opposite it's not the proper it creates
the wrong frame it's not the word
opposite it isn't even part of the story
um
and and you know if we think about the
if we think about the magnitude of the
notion of creation itself in
relationship with the epic phenomenon of
human civilization
that which is possible in the context of
simply expressing the logos properly in
kairos
is not a historical event
we can't sort of measure it against
historical events that's nonsense it's
like saying you can't stack two grains
of sand upon the other
um
all that has happened in the long arc of
human history is as nothing in
relationship to the potential that is
embedded in the creation itself
so to the degree to which
even a small number of people come to a
capacity to
speak the logos or express the logos
with integrity and humility then we
literally have no possibility of
understanding exactly what might follow
nor should we endeavor to do so ours is
not to understand it ours is simply to
endeavor to do it as well as we can
um again within tremendous humility
um
so that's the what came for me as a in
response to that that last little bit
i think i think i mean i think your
point is very powerful and i think that
it talks about this idea too of the seed
you know this image for example of
of the ark
is a is a good one because you'd think
you know the arc
noah's ark is just this little dot in
the notion of of breakdown and chaos and
everything falling apart but
that's it like that's that's it that's
all we can do
is to let's say manifest the seed and
then that will
grow you know with with time as the as
the the shift happens
then then it's it really is in a way the
only thing we can do
um
right
okay i i get that
but i still want to press the socratic
point which is the virtuosity and virtue
of the logos in relationship to the
hyper agents
these are virtues and virtuosities that
we are not
properly explicating and cultivating
right now in our culture right if
putting this
like here's the emerging ontology this
is reality saying i'm going to break
into everything you thought you made
that's what's happening right that's
what the hyper objects and the parasitic
entities are doing and i like this idea
that they're degradations of the
hyperagents the in-between i think
that's beautiful
but then okay how do i exer how do i not
exercise this wrong word how do i
participate
in the virtuosity and virtue of logos
with these
aspects of my ontology given that they
are eruptions into what what has been a
stable on top the ontology is being
destabilized right it's entering right
and so
i you know this comes up
it comes up for me in my practices yeah
right like how what is it like
in or what is it like to
exercise i keep saying exercise to
practice that's the word i want to
practice the participation
of the virtuosity and the virtues
of logos with respect to the emerging
aspects of the ontology
right that to me
like i say this is not an abstract
problem this comes up for me alexio
divina this comes up for me in
philosophical fellowship this comes up
for me and dialectic into dialogues
and that's what i think i want like i i
i'm
sorry i i'm i'm getting compassion but
that's the part that i really want to
bring into
right
into prominence
we have a kind of
you might not agree with me on this
jonathan but to my mind it looks like we
have a profound ignorance about this and
first of all we have to admit the
ignorance
that's socrates and then secondly what
how are we going to respond to it how
are we going to respond like
i i
i'll stop
[Laughter]
so i mean i think that that the surprise
is maybe that
there's a in this world of kind of
breakdown what one of the problems that
happens is that the person who's trying
to humbly express logos will appear as a
thorn at first
and then and then my
might not make it i don't know what to
say i might not make it you know might
just be there to plant the seed and
might not make it into the
into the holy land you know well said oh
yeah yeah well yeah
i would say that this is this is a very
um i would say
yes
in fact it seems quite likely that
making it to the whole end is not part
of the not part of the gig they're part
of the plan
and that's okay that's okay
um so so this is another okay i think i
feel that what was happening earlier
more clearly um
okay not make something up
yes
which is to say something like
what is
what is real
being in relationship with what is real
right one is not creating what is not
the creator one is being in relationship
with what is real and one is allowing
the creation to flow through
um
hold on
so
there's maybe two or three there's
several moves that come up that seem to
be proper
uh one which is clearly incredibly
challenging
is merely perceiving reality for what it
is
um ah okay yeah so where i want to go
with that and i'll say a little bit more
but i want to hold this because this is
what it feels like the most meaningful
at this moment is
the
the nature of reality which is
transcendent which is to say that there
is a
this is very much connected to jonathan
i think some of the things are in that
essay
jesus
not words yeah that which is is not that
which we can say
uh and yet it is not without order right
there is a
a sort of necessity or a proper order to
being
which is intrinsic to being
and that we can discern and this of
course is
invariant under transformation to use a
contemporary geometric language and
provides a ground against which we can
orient our choices uh in regardless of
the fact of con chaos in the larger sort
of actual
uh human context so that's
that's a big piece um maybe it's the
only piece
the other one you're right you're so
right because but it also one of the
things that happens when you orient
yourself properly in a world of chaos is
that it really does
it it shines brighter actually probably
than in a world where all things are are
going their own way
so you know and so it actually can
really act as a transformative agent for
good and ill like people will hate you
and then some people will love you but
it can't
you know if you are if you're that mean
a good example would be that if you're
in a corrupt world and you decide you're
going to tell the truth
you will have an effect there's no way
around it they might kill you they might
get rid of you all of this might happen
but you'll have a transformative effect
because that light will shine in the
darkness there's no way around it
yeah so john flipping it to the language
of virtue
um
there's two ways of being in
relationship with virtue um one
something along the lines of sort of a a
conservation law of evolutionary process
so
you know an adequately large number of
blind people sort of feeling around in a
uh
in a maze will find their way through
the maze right and they may remember it
they may like try to write it down and
say hey left right right left left
that's how you get out yeah that's the
the human beings living in cultures
surviving and dying and discovering the
things like humility and courage and
integrity
if you if you have those woven deeply
into the nature of your culture you're
going to be more likely to live well
than others right it's sort of that
perspective right that way of looking at
it the other way of looking at it of
course is you simply turn on the light
and you look at the maze and you notice
there's there's actually a structure to
the maze and there's a way of noticing
just how to get through it without
having to go through the process of
searching groping with your with your
eyes closing your hands out
um and this is what i was referring to
earlier right so
the proposition is that both of these
are accurate like both these are very
valid ways
um and that there's something like our
capacity now where we are now as as
humans
is
we can be aware of that and we can say
okay there is actually a beautiful
almost like a hint
um
a clue
to
this thing virtue the virtues
that is hard worn we can look back at
the history of history and say okay
here's where these things have shown up
here's the edges and the parameters the
shapes of the thing but now we actually
are in a process where we can and i
would say must
turn on the light and we have to in fact
become capable of perceiving that and
use the the evolutionary process to kind
of act as a scaffold and a support
but step
to the last you know that next step that
is available which is beyond what's
available through trial and error
because we haven't got any time left to
engage in trial and error we have to
become
really significantly virtuous and the
best way to do that is to actually have
a much better sense of the nature of
what the underlying
intrinsic order is that has been
constantly rediscovered and rediscovered
and rediscovered
um and then jonathan something that
keeps coming up for me and i think this
is very much connected to a stream that
i've noticed coming from you and i'll
say it in a very different way because
it creates a space
i spent a lot of time last year with the
hawaiians
and
they taught me substantially about the
validity and importance of restoration
for them politically but also from a
point of view of lineage from the point
of view of a
culture that
spent a lot of time figuring out how to
actually create a way of holding
perception of reality and making
effective choices
well
and
as they taught me their language
i discovered that
it didn't have a whole lot of the
corruptions that the language that i was
taught as a child namely english
so something very powerful also about
restoration and then john you and i've
been spending a lot of time restoring
english and in some sense
yes
and rediscovering for me like as a as
just an ordinary kind of secular western
uh capitalism suburbs kid
what the word faith maybe really means
right not not the
seventh order derivative of propaganda
faith that has been sort of
loosely insulated and integrated into my
mind but what it may actually mean and
therefore a restoration to its proper
place and so
this notion of healing or bringing back
into wholesomeness
the restoration of the lineages that are
were developed in integrity in
relationship with actual reality and did
their living best to build structures
that would hold and transmit that
capacity to thrive in relationships
reality into the future is a profound
now it's a fundamental move
um and sits to the right hand of simply
turning on the light
i i agree
with this like profoundly um
i i think what i need to do is bring a
concrete in um to like so i was involved
in philosophical fellowship practice and
what you do is you
somebody reads a text very slowly and
then somebody picks out the uh the first
reader usually picks out a phrase you
you chant the phrase and then you do
what's called pray you do a kind of
speech
uh precious speaking anyways the point
is in this practice you're not speaking
to the text you're addressing the pres
you're trying to presence the
perspective of the author
so you're trying to actually
uh presence the perspective of the sage
so you can enter into conformity
uh to the
the perspective of this age not just
taking information from their
propositions
this is a way of trying to bring about a
transformative relationship to texts so
that they have the capacity for
transformation other than just
information
now what happens is
people and
and this is part of what i teach people
to do
we were reading a passage from simone de
beauvoir and what starts to happen is
other people start to they start to
speak things that you can't think about
the text and they they begin they start
to become the voice of simone
in a way that's hard to explain because
you get a sense of wow that's all there
and i didn't see it and the other people
are speaking it and everybody's doing
this
and then there's a pivot point and i did
this deliberately and provocatively
because i've been doing it in my
practice where people i i don't just
talk about you know
i don't just talk third person i shifted
to second person address
and i said simone
and a couple of one other person picked
it up layman picked it up and he
immediately started doing that
right and and two other people said they
wanted to do that
they wanted to do that they wanted to
take an eye thou rather than an eye-it
or an i-me which is how all the
discourse was going i yet i me they
wanted to take a night out and they were
choked
they couldn't do it
they couldn't do it
and i said well challenging the choke is
where i'm finding most of the
transformation i'm saying i'm not
claiming that i'm sort of
you know resurrecting
simone de beauvoir but i'm also not just
talking to her text i'm trying to do
something else right and what it is is
for me what happens is the logos of her
texts is present and it conveys
something that was
both universal and particular about her
and i'm trying to address that and
trying to get right
and and the pro and i find
and people said it's it's uncanny and
it's weird and i'm and i'm really you
know and there's part of me that's like
yeah it's uncanny and it's weird but
it's also if i stay behind that choke
point i don't get the full impact
of the process right there's and i
thwart the capacity to internalize
simone de beauvoir uh about right and
and and for me
that would be a loss because she has a
particular understanding
of
the female perspective that i think is
valuable for a lot of people
and i'm not advocating for this
no but i i think do you think maybe that
i mean this is this might be might seem
a little torturous on my part to say
this but do you think that maybe the
choke came from the fact that people
didn't think that simone de beauvoir is
worth praying to
maybe that's just where the choke came
from it was no
i i i it could have been i thought about
that but but the people were very honest
and in fact they wanted to talk about
why they were choking and it was more
they it was more
towards something we talked about
earlier that it was the liminality of
this the in-betweenness uh they wanted
to say
like
simone is like
you know the
i got a strong sense of the presence of
the perspective
because i make a distinction between the
presence of the perspective and the
full-blown presence of the person right
um and
and they said but that the it was that
that was uncanny for them and they they
they
didn't want to speak it
precisely because
it would disturb
the sort of stability of their
categories
that was the sense i was getting it was
introducing them to a third way in which
things are real neither subjectively nor
objectively there's this other way
they're real the way lerman talks about
in her book how god becomes real and
that third way of things being real
was deeply disturbing to them so this is
i'm using this as to say i think if we
try to enter into
the
logos with these emerging aspects of
reality we're going to be encountering
this third way in which things are real
and people find it very very challenging
that's now
i don't know yet i i i understand what
you're saying too jonathan and i i i
think i i'm not just i'm not denying
that that can also be a possibility i
don't think that was the case in the
particular instance i was in
yeah i would just i'll invoke
that piece
we westerners particularly americans
for the past oh probably the totality of
our being for the past 200 years or so
have been unreasonably reckless with
regard to this particular question so
i'm noticing the importance of what
jonathan is presenting
um okay so creating our proper
boundaries and we're entering into a
space john is john is pointing out hey
there's a uh
there's this place this is way of being
a relationship
that is real and important and present
to the moment we're in
jonathan is saying yes by the way we
know a lot about this place be very
careful when you enter that yes yes yes
right
that's exactly my point though i i in
fact if that's what you if that's what
jonathan is saying that's exactly my
point i that's what i'm trying to get at
with virtuosity
and virtue the proper
care of this third way in which things
are real
because i agree with you just flinging
yourself into it is is extremely foolish
right yeah that's the point i'm bringing
up that's exactly the challenge i'm
posing because there was a moment like
this at the end of the 19th century you
know when we have all these occultists
that are very present
so you have this moment where all of a
sudden people started to notice that
they could engage with these
these beings and they could they could
they could have seances they could
manifest them they could get together
and then you know someone would channel
something else and they became very
fascinated by that because it was like
hey something's happening this is cool
it's like kids playing with the ouija
board right it's like hey look this is
actually doing something and so and i
think that that's that's maybe my my
reservation towards this type of
behavior is that
that
there are
is that it will
just because something happens
and that things you can engage
these
these types of of beings or these types
of residues of beings let's say
uh
it yes i think that there's a danger in
that and i this is i i talked about that
in terms of fascination with this with
how people become fascinated by the fact
that all of a sudden they're able to
perceive these these let's say uh hyper
agents and and higher beings and so
because of that they lack the the
discernment and knowing why would i
engage
and how and what is the proper way to do
so is it just out of curiosity is it
just out of uh you know what is it that
i'm trying to accomplish and i am i just
trying to have some spiritual experience
am i is this aimed towards a higher good
uh yeah and so those are all the
questions that i would that i would
definitely ask
i agree and and
just to give you
probably not complete reassurance but at
least some that is all part of what i
what is going on in these practices
right those questions are asked deeply
and seriously uh but yeah i do worry i
do worry about the the the the
sort of
potential polarity here which is
like a foolish fascination
uh or or or or kind of a
and i i don't mean this necessarily
religiously a fundamentalism that says
no no there is no change to our ontology
possible those are the two things we're
trying to sail between
here um and
that's for me
uh like i think we need
sorry
this is almost funny to say uh well but
we need sort of new virtues
or or at least a a a a reinventio of
uh of of some of the older virtues i i
don't know quite what i'm saying but
like how to properly like we like orient
in that is the thing that i'm i'm
bumping up against
um um
or maybe we need something like a
fullness of
virtues in the sense that jordan talked
about which is that there's a manner in
which we've noticed a degrading of the
words that we use we've noticed the
degrading of words like faith words like
beauty words like truth you know and so
we've noticed that happening where now
beauty just becomes pleasure you know
yes where faith just becomes believing
in something unreasonable so we have
these weird transformations that have
happened over the past 500 years and so
by recovering the actual
the the actual highest version of these
of these terms and of these
meanings then we we run less of
less a danger of going astray let's say
and it's there like you i mean and i
think john you know that that's why like
i go back to
at least the authors the christian
authors that i think have captured the
highest version of christianity in their
work it's like it's like saint gregory
saint maximus you know uh these are
these are the saints that seem to have
had the highest vision of what it is
that that that that these virtues or the
way in which we can embody this reality
in the world today is and so and the
same with the philosophers like you know
going to the neoplaton is going to to
back to plato these are the ways that we
can we can do this and i and i'm trying
to do that yeah
so like and and and yeah and jordan's
right yeah we're like that that i i like
the latin term inventio to discover and
and and also to create uh
like like the the work i've the work
i've been doing and the conversations
i've been having about trying to
reintegrate phenomenology
with the theory of the forms so it
doesn't become this abstract notion but
becomes this process the ethetic
identication of literally trying to
practice finding the through line
through line in our intelligibility
that's what i mean about and if you're
right that is in a sense a recovery of
plato but it's a recovery of plato that
benefits from things after plato like
phenomenology right and marla ponti
right and so i'm very much trying to do
that and i i i guess what i'm
asking for
and it's it's too great of an ask i get
it but i'm trying to get like that i i'm
trying to see how that
right and
and and and
how that can be brought into
like the the proper deal logos
relationship uh two
because i agree with you i too
the the the that's again why i like you
i'm exploring neoplatonism so deeply
about how can we get a proper
understanding of
the orders of
agency if you if you want to put it that
way
so that we can
just avoid just
you know
the foolish fascination which is rampant
but also the opposite which is rampant
which is no no no no everything is fine
you stay with the ontology we've always
had just work harder boxer just work
harder right um
and so
sorry i
i hope this is being helpful i feel for
like me like i'm moving forward in this
conversation i hope the two of you also
feel that as well
definitely
i have a i have a before where because i
said we go until two if you have a few
more minutes
it seems like there's a good reason to
talk about this just because it happened
with it yesterday or a few days ago uh
if you followed this story about the
google employee who
who declared lambda one of the ai boxes
okay uh and so
so i i mean i'm asking about its
sentience i think is is irrelevant at
least to me the actual sentience of the
the program but the the idea that this
is let's say that there's a scandal
related to that there's a scandal which
is finding media attention related to
someone saying this getting fired or
getting suspended because they are
saying this have you put any thought
into that into what's going on right now
yeah i have i mean first of all
my whole career has been the pr these
pronouncements
uh minsky famously said in 1967 within
10 years computers won't even be keeping
us as pets we have to be really we have
to be my response to any of these claims
are initially
skeptical uh when the when the first
versions of these came out like
what are their names one is jurassic and
the other what is it cpt3 or something
right oh look look it passes the trench
all you do is just take the two of them
and have them talk to each other for one
minute and they spin off in really weird
[ __ ] really fast right so there's a
problem with you know human beings
interacting with these things and saying
ah because human beings have a
tremendous capacity to find salient find
sentience in things that might not
properly be sentient right and so that
to my mind first of all that's not the
right test
right the right test is for us to
actually have them talk to each other
and see if it goes off because that is
much more powerful because they very
quickly reciprocally narrow into
weirdness
which and and that is the way of telling
whether or not you've got a simulation
and then in the sense that jordan was
saying or you've got an actual
instantiation so as a cognitive
scientist that's my first response i
want to see the correct test
right and i especially don't want to
hear the test of somebody that might
have been involved in the creation of
this because they're going to be heavily
invested right this is not a good
scientific test
that being said we might come to the day
where that's the case however i doubt
that it's going to be the kind of
machines that are being offered right
now because there's good reason i think
to believe that for there to be real
intelligence general intelligence you
have to be embodied you have to be
uh you have to be so you have to be
properly social you have to be emotional
et cetera et cetera et cetera um the
fact that our categories
for
terms like sentience are so impoverished
that everybody freaks out
that's to me the thing to really pay
attention to here like why isn't it that
we get like oh
well here we've got a well thought out
understanding of intelligence and
sentience and consciousness let's
discuss it and bring it to bear on this
problem no no no we freak out we we we
we create some sort of crypto conspiracy
theory
and like like what like for me it's like
is if this is what it claims to be it is
a scientific discovery and should be
responded to in that fashion the worst
people to ask are the creator of it
right the media and the politicians
this is properly
right a scientific question and i would
want to i want a journalist somewhere
somewhere in that mix it's just yeah
general purpose makes things worse
what we right so
as a cognitive scientist
i have suspicions about it uh because
generally these machines are completely
syntactic in nature and they work in
terms of probability distributions which
means human beings can easily comport
themselves and they will perform
fantastically but it's very quickly easy
to reveal monster monstrosity doesn't
mean there isn't real progress being
made there by the way
jordan do you have something to say
about this
yes i do go for it
so um
maybe maybe a way of putting would be
something like it's
this thing that we've been talking about
a lot
the simulation
and the naming that i said that maybe
we've been living 85 percent of our
lives as humans civilized humans for the
past say 30 or so thousand years
in a simulation i'm going to say that
that
is
a paperclip optimizer if you're familiar
with that notion from kind of ai ai has
this this this metaphor of
of a risk of what happens if you produce
a super intelligent ai
and task it
with the responsibility of producing the
most efficient maximum number of paper
clips
and it accidentally converts the entire
earth into nothing but a floating cloud
of gravitationally balanced paper clips
so a paperclip maximizer this is
basically all that happens is when you
you yoke intelligence separate from
sentience and sapience or yes
soul
uh to a narrow
local optimization function right so we
describe civilization in more or less
that same fashion and it it it is that
mob it is that unconscious it is the egg
rewards in that earth that sort of
variation that we were sort of brushing
on a little bit
um
you know so i would take not the
opposite i'll take another perspective
on this most recent uh what you call it
fad that's not bad fad's not bad
the silliness
with which
such a large fraction of our collective
intelligence
was effusively oriented towards
something
is is just evidence
of the ease by which a relatively
mediocre ai
if improperly deployed
could take advantage of our lower
natures and the decadent corruption and
otherwise
uh profane aspects of our of the paper
clip maximizer in which we live
to further the process of converting us
all into paper clips
that's
so beautiful this is the problem that i
see
um it's less a problem of sort of like
everything's hunky-dory but we
accidentally create you know terminator
2 or something like that
it's more like it's all part of this of
a reciprocal narrowing that we call
civilization and that we're living
within and we need to actually find our
way out of that in general um
can i can i loop a little bit of this
last piece about um
let's just say prayer the way you
described it jonathan you said perhaps i
didn't want to pray to simone
um
over a few years ago i found myself in
an interesting conversation with some
a variety of different folks from the
north american indigenous community
different different different bands and
tribes
and somebody said something i thought
was quite nice he said that um
in silicon valley there's a phrase that
has uh how would you call it
it's just has obvious currency which is
information wants to be free
and he said to his people
nothing more absurd could possibly be
uttered
that information is quite often
extremely dangerous and
uh the proper thing is to have the
proper people holding the proper
competencies in a proper way in support
of what is in fact a wholesome way of
life
um and in some sense it's obvious we
don't want to give the sort of the keys
to the nuclear codes to literally
everybody
um
but these this is true in general if you
really think about it all the way
through this capacity to be humans in
relationship with being
and to speak
meaning and world is profoundly powerful
uh and ai just happens to be an example
of that profound power but but the whole
point is the whole [ __ ] thing is
profoundly powerful
and
learning how to
enter into right relationship with that
capacity particularly since we're in
media's rest and we're sort of
none of us are grown-ups yet all of us
have capacity
is
quite meaningfully important right now
and so what i would propose is to take
the thing that sort of practice that you
were talking about john
dear logos and for almost everybody
the safe place to practice neologos
is like with your wife
or with your child
around ordinary life
like the simplest most basic ordinary
wholesome human experiences
practice dlo goes there
until you're very good at it
then consider the possibility of moving
into more sort of
potent practices of d logos by the way
you won't be able to help but it will
simply enter more and more and more into
your life
um but the more it's grounded to
ordinary life the more is grounded to
how we are just making the choice that's
in front of you better
the more it's able to be in service to
ordinary life and then it is woven back
into liviness and not in the space where
we bring things into sorcery surface
from the top down yeah yeah
wrong top by the way from the simulated
top down which gets in the way of our
relationship with the top
um
and that like that distinction strikes
me as being sort of a fundamental
distinction at this moment which the
distinction between sorcery and theodia
or the distinction you made in practice
yeah the distinction of practice the
distinction of
weaving our potency and relationship
with meaningfulness within relationship
with life the actual the real actual
life that you're living moment to moment
bring it into service of that first
and keep it at that level of scale
and don't do the sorcerer's apprentice
thing and avoid the sports as a precious
thing at all costs
once you've become capable of bringing a
higher degree of beauty and life and
life aliveness in the relationships that
are directly in front of you then expand
you know build that capacity if by the
way that is yours to do this goes back
to the notion of living kairos properly
if it turns out that your moment of
living kairos properly is to bring
something in service to the logos in a
powerful way then do what is yours to do
um
probably still practice
you know to do it artfully in in in a
very powerful way
no i think i think that that's probably
at least for me
that's probably a great way to finish
this i think you're totally right and i
think it does wrap up a little bit all
the things that we're saying that is
that
that we have a certain
amount of capacity to affect the world
and that that is
especially like if we think of
hyperagents for example like the the big
the closest hybrid agent you'll have to
deal with is your family like that is
the closest one that you have
with you and it's like you can build
that into something that isn't parasitic
and that is that is together in a higher
in higher participation then i think
that it's like maybe that's the best
thing it can do you know apart from that
i would actually say one one thing
closer yeah for almost all beings alive
today the closest type of agent is
yourself yeah exactly i was actually
going exactly there they're gonna say
apart from like
bringing all these broken processes
within you together in yourself like
then then after that like you said it's
with your your your close
close people so
so guys thanks for this conversation i
definitely would like to
to continue it and to have more because
i i think that this is the question that
everybody is thinking about and
everybody's asking so i need some time
to think about what we talked about
today but i would like to continue if
you if you agree well
then i'll end with a provocation go for
it provoke us john the advice that you
both made is good advice
the problem is that
again
we're
i think we also need to get people into
a relationship with
people other than their family and their
friends this is the notion of fellowship
and that
we need that and we need part of the
fellowship and to use your language
jonathan we need part of the fellowship
is the communion of the saints
and that um
they have to be part of the family too
in some way if
if plato and socrates
can't enter
and be part of my family then i'm kind
of doomed
in a way
so i don't want to i'm not rejecting the
advice you gave
but i'm turning it into a provocation
granted what you said is correct jordan
and i agree with jonathan and i think it
is right nevertheless
right
well there's a very beautiful way of
synthesizing that which is to remember
that the word family means those who
love most
yes
right all right well that's great and uh
and i'll i'll give my last provocation
to you john i'll say that's why i tell
people to go to church
[Laughter]
well okay so i'll stop talking uh i just
want to say thank you guys thanks to
both of you this has been wonderful and
uh we'll definitely set up i
i really like that with me saying yes to
any future conversation all right
me too i really found that uh
there was a tripoli thing between us
that really gave a powerful field of
exploration i really felt the logos
coming into the conversation very
powerfully um and so just thank you both
thank you very much all right well
thank you and we'll talk again all right
take care